et je n'arrêtais pas de parler de mon innocence
de l'injustice, de la trahison et de la tromperie,
jusqu'à ce que finalement, tout comme cette femme,
les gens me fuient,
jusqu'à ce que je me rende finalement compte
que je ne digérais pas mes sentiments,
je les nourrissais.
Je ne voulais pas laisser mourir cette version crucifiée de moi-même.
Mais nous savons tous qu'avec chaque histoire de résurrection,
il faut d'abord mourir.
L'histoire chrétienne,
Jésus était mort dans le tombeau pendant une journée
avant d'être ressuscité.
Et je crois que pour nous,
être dans le tombeau
signifie faire un profond travail sur nous-même
autour de nos blessures
et nous autoriser à guérir.
Nous devons laisser mourir cette version crucifiée de nous-même
pour qu'une nouvelle version de nous, une version plus authentique,
naisse.
Nous devons nous affranchir de cette vieille histoire
pour qu'une nouvelle histoire, une histoire plus authentique,
puisse être racontée.
Proclamez votre expérience. Ne la laissez pas vous proclamer.
Et s'il n'y avait pas de survivants,
je veux dire, et si les gens décidaient
simplement de proclamer leur traumatisme comme une expérience
plutôt que de le revêtir comme une identité ?
Peut-être que cela marquerait la fin
de notre emprisonnement dans nos blessures
et le début de merveilleuses
explorations, découvertes et développements personnels.
Peut-être que ce serait le début de la définition de nous-même
par qui nous sommes devenus
et qui nous sommes en train de devenir.
Peut-être que survivant n'était pas
l'une des trois choses que vous m'auriez dites.
Ce n'est pas grave.
Je souhaite juste que vous sachiez tous
que je suis très heureuse que nous soyons ensemble dans ce bus,
et voici mon arrêt.
(Applaudissements)